[Music]  was anything like you know and this is  completely safe yes we do these are our  loans all the time  [Music]  ready to go yeah I guess  [Music]  you shut that thing off everywhere I  goes I've got a camera in my face this  is the time to retire because everyone's  got a camera everyone's got a lawyer I'm  retiring at the right time I was the cop  at the right time you're gonna have a  lot of crap to deal with five minutes  not here to play any game  my ride-along we got to find out  oh hang on Mac let's give us something  else to worry about there now can only  get to this active shooter as quick as  possible you were an hour late and we  were out gunned there's a lot  you